wenn er die sache tatsächlich etwas dran
ist dann wäre das eine absolute
sensation und wir würden wahrscheinlich
schon bald leben auf dem mars finden
einige medien hatten gemeldet dass die
us-raumfahrtbehörde bereits vor rund 40
jahren also die nasa bei der viking
mission organische moleküle auf dem mars
gefunden habe diese dann aber
versehentlich bei der analyse verbrannt
hatte wie genau soll das damals
abgelaufen sein
und was ist dran an dieser mysteriösen
behauptung klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
das war vor 42 jahren der absolute
hammer im juli 1976 landete die berühmte
nasa sonde viking 1 auf dem mars einige
wochen später auch ihre schwester
sondern die erste erfolgreiche landung
auf dem mars überhaupt die mission
bestand aus zwei anbietern die den mars
umkreisten und zwei ländern die auf dem
roten planeten auf setzten schon beim
landeanflug jubelte das forschungsteam
denn der forschung des maßnahmen endlich
konkrete züge an dazu der nasa
historiker glencores das war das erste
mal dass wir gute daten bekam zum
beispiel aus der oberen atmosphäre bevor
die physik des wiedereintritt sein thema
war dann konnten wir sehen wie langsam
sich der länder durch die atmosphäre
bewegte wie dicht sie war die temperatur
so dass wir die hitzeschilde besser
verstehen könnten vier experimente waren
an bord der beiden sonden das ziel der
mission fotos der landesstelle machen
lebendige organismen im boden aufspüren
und tatsächlich die mission hatte am
ende spektakuläre fotos biologische
analysen und wetterdaten zum ergebnis
und sie prägten das bild vom mars wie
man es bis in die 90er jahre hatte doch
die eigentliche frage nach leben auf
anderen planeten lieferten nicht die
gewünschte jahr antwort die den weg
freigemacht hätte für weitere maßnahmen
letztendlich lieferten die vier
experimente kein eindeutiges ergebnis zu
dieser frage
die resultate waren schwer zu erklären
und konnten stattdessen so oder so
interpretiert werden
handelte es sich nur um chemische
reaktionen im zusammenhang mit dem mars
boden oder waren sie doch als hinweis
auf organisches leben auf dem mars zu
interpretieren beispielsweise beim
stoffwechsel experimentier gab es bei
der ersten probe von viking 1 ein
positives resultat dass die
forschungsteams damals euphorisierte der
anstieg der zähler deutet zunächst auf
einen hohen umsatz wert eines
stoffwechsels hin also wie bei uns bei
menschen die verdauung bei der weiteren
zugabe von erle lösungen allerdings sank
der wert wieder also leben hätte hier
mit einem weiteren anstieg
reagieren müssen dafür war die blind
probe unauffällig also doch ein hinweis
auf organisches leben
auch das photosynthese experiment
lieferte leichte positive resultate
dennoch waren die ergebnisse auch hier
nicht wirklich eindeutig der
wissenschaftlichen diskurs über die
frage ging weiter jahrelang wurde auch
vermutet dass bereits vor dem start der
sonde organisches material der erde in
die häfen gelangt war dass es auf dem
mars komplexe organische moleküle gibt
das wissen wir mit voller mit sicherheit
ja seit 2012 das hatte kurjo city
bewiesen der mars rover hatte
kohlenstoffhaltigen verbindungen
aufgespürt die als wichtige
voraussetzung für leben gelten erst im
juni hatte die nasa gemeldet dass
curiosity weitere wichtige bausteine für
leben entdeckt hatte die analyse der
gesteinsproben die übrigens auf ein
alter von mehr als 3,5 milliarden jahren
geschätzt werden ergab wohl auch
organische verbindungen wie mit tier
fäden
das ist ein hinweis darauf dass die
klimatischen bedingungen in der
untersuchten meeresregion vor allen
dingen milliarden jahren wohl
lebensfreundlich gewesen sein könnten
doch das rätsel der wiki missionen von
vor 40 jahren ist immer noch nicht
geklärt ein forschungsteam der nasa
selbst hat jetzt versucht erklärung zu
finden und jetzt haltet euch fest die
vermutung steht im raum dass die eine
der beiden viking einheiten tatsächlich
organisches material aufgespürt hatte
dieser wichtige fund dann aber bei der
datenanalyse in der ferngesteuerten
maschine verbrannt wurde aus versehen
ursache für dieses malheur könnte nach
ansicht des forschungsteams die
verbindung namens perchlorat seien eine
art brandbeschleuniger
die chemikalie wird auch hier auf der
erde im brandbeschleunigern eingesetzt
diese plaques perchlorat wurden vor etwa
zehn jahren auf dem mars aufgespürt und
zwar durch die lande sonde phoenix
sie könnten auch dafür gesorgt haben
dass sich die öfen damals stärker
erhitzt hatten als geplant dabei könnten
sich die empfindlichen proben in den
öfen viking länder entzündet haben so
dass diese zerstört wurden diese
hypothese bestätigt
das aktuelle forschungsteam jetzt dieses
szenarios nach ansicht der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sogar noch wahrscheinlicher geworden
seitdem der jüngste mal sommer 2013
nicht nur organische moleküle sondern
auch chlor benzol moleküle aufgespürt
hatte denn diese entstehen bei der
reaktion von kohlenstoff und präparaten
und auch die landeeinheit viking 2 hatte
wohl spuren von benzol entdeckt
berichtete das nasa forschung das team
jetzt doch so klar ist das ganze
szenario dann wohl doch nicht schlecht
schließlich ist immer noch nicht
ausgeschlossen dass die öfen mit
material von der erde verunreinigt lagen
auch diese moleküle könnten mit den
bergleuten reagiert haben
ein gegenargument allerdings ist dass
die kohlenstoff artigen substanzen von
der erde eigentlich schon bei
niedrigeren temperaturen hätten
reagieren müssen ja vielleicht wird uns
aber die exomars mission die 2020 auf
dem roten planeten landen soll weitere
erkenntnisse dazu bringen es ist also
tatsächlich möglich dass wir schon bald
leben auf dem mars entdecken wenn ihr
kein video dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann und geht er die
kaputte auto boxer auf youtube wo also
nur manchmal sagen mag oder wozu ein
video auftaucht von am kanal den er
abonniert habt und verpasst kann wie du
denn über whatsapp der vater der familie
persönlich vor jedem upload vor allen
anderen also tag dicht garantiert wenn
im video online gilt einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
social media welt dafür hier klicken
aber nicht die genau die glocke
vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken außerirdisches leben
auf dem mars
neue indizien bis dann bleibt dran